Marvel’s Daredevil on Netflix looks set
to be the new superhero series to beat, giving
Arrow and The Flash quite a run for their
vigilante money.
Forget 2003’s Daredevil movie starring Ben
Affleck, which mixed po-faced melodrama with
cheesy cartoony elements.
This new Daredevil series is an entirely different
beast and takes Marvel into darker, grittier
territory than we’ve seen before while still
firmly locating the world of our new small-screen
superhero within the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
With 13 episodes of about 50 minutes each
to play with, Daredevil takes an enjoyably
slow-build approach to introducing us to Matt
Murdock, a brilliant blind lawyer by day and
a violent masked vigilante by night.
Through a series of flashbacks cleverly integrated
into Murdock’s present-day story, we find
out how he came to be a street-level hero
with enhanced senses, a vigilante on a mission
to save his city.
The show has a feeling of realism that’s
due to many things: there’s the performances
of the actors themselves, there’s the Hell’s
Kitchen setting and New York filming locations,
there’s how the fight scenes are staged,
and there’s the way the writers gradually
build up the layers of these characters and
their stories.
And then there’s the show’s darkness,
both in terms of its appearance and its attitude.
Even the series’ opening credits look like
they’re dripping blood.
Murdock lives in the deliberately murky-looking
neighbourhood of Hell’s Kitchen in a New
York City still dealing with the aftermath
of the Avengers’ first assembly.
There’s a feeling of film noir in the playful
use of shadows in the show, and a distinct
air of 1970s American movies like Taxi Driver
in the its grounded grittiness.
And that edginess extends to the script and
its unflinching commitment not to shy away
from the intense and, at times, brutal nature
of Murdock’s story.
From what I’ve seen of the series so far,
Murdock’s Daredevil doesn’t shrink from
violence or meting out justice as he feels
fit.
Imagine the Oliver Queen we met in Season
1 of Arrow on steroids!
Among those who deserve credit for Daredevil’s
quite daring tone are executive producer Drew
Goddard, who very much sets the mood with
his writing on the first two episodes, showrunner
Steven DeKnight, and the series’ cinematographer
Matthew Lloyd.
As for the cast, Charlie Cox puts in a pitch-perfect
performance as both super-smart and super-charming
lawyer Matt Murdock, and his kick-ass, power-punching
alter-ego Daredevil, whose initial black costume
fits well with the show’s dark themes.
Elden Henson brings a real likeability to
Foggy, who’s Murdock’s friend and partner-in-law,
and he also adds a nice line in humour, throwing
some light among the show’s shadows.
Plus, there’s a lovely, natural chemistry
between Henson’s Foggy and True Blood star
Deborah Ann Woll, who plays their first client,
Karen Page.
As nurse Claire Temple, Rosario Dawson’s
time on the show is certainly off to an interesting
start.
And Vincent D’Onofrio’s turn as shadowy
businessman Wilson Fisk is nicely understated,
with an ever-present hint of danger.
While Toby Leonard Moore hits all the right
notes as Fisk’s right-hand man, Wesley.
And Vondie Curtis-Hall is totally convincing
as old-fashioned newspaper journalist Ben,
who wants to unearth stories that make a difference.
And if it’s action you’re after, you certainly
won’t be disappointed with Daredevil.
There are plenty of amazing fight scenes,
which mix down-and-dirty brawling with martial
arts influences to great effect.
The show’s stunt team, including stunt and
fight co-ordinator Philip J Silvera, really
have done a superb job.
Oh, and listen out for the sound during those
fights – it's bone-crunchingly intense!
After watching the first five episodes of
Daredevil, I cannot wait to watch the rest!
And I’m now even more excited to see the
other street-level hero series that Marvel’s
got up its sleeve, including AKA Jessica Jones,
Iron Fist, and Luke Cage; all of whose main
characters will team up with Daredevil in
The Defenders.
Lots to look forward to!
So, to sum up: Daredevil is a delectably dark
dive into the world of Marvel’s popular
street-level hero.
Combining an incredible cast and awesome stunts
with a smart slow-burn script, the series
shows that justice can be both blind and bloody.
Daredevil gets 4.5 out of 5 Flicks.
When you’ve seen Daredevil, tell me what
you think of the show.
How excited are you for Marvel’s upcoming
TV shows AKA Jessica Jones, Luke Cage and
Iron Fist?
And who’s your favourite superhero on the
big or small screen & why?
Let me know in the comments below!
If you like this video, hit the thumbs-up
button & subscribe for my weekly reviews and
interviews!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, superhero lovers!